il est venu en médiateur pour tenter
d'apaiser les tensions qui agitent
l'ancienne république soviétique
le président du conseil européen s'est
entretenu de longues heures avec le
premier ministre géorgien avant de tenir
une conférence de presse au côté de la
présidente du pays
après avoir assuré que bruxelles prenait
la situation au sérieux
charles michel se dit déterminé à
trouver une solution pour apaiser la
situation
la visite arrive dans un contexte une
crise politique qui s'aggrave en georgie
cela préoccupe beaucoup
l'union européenne l'union européenne
appelle toutes les parties à intensifier
leurs efforts pour désamorcer la
situation et se réunir pour trouver un
terrain d'entente
de son côté la présidence géorgienne a
accepté la main tendue par bruxelles
elle se dit prête à discuter avec
l'opposition
au cours de notre réunion
nous avons discuté en détail de la
situation politique
nous avons convenu qu aujourd'hui le
pays a besoin de stabilité interne de
réconciliation de dialogue
c'est le seul moyen pour la géorgie de
récolter les fruits des efforts fournis
sur le chemin de l'union européenne la
visite de charles michel survient alors
que les manifestations se multiplient
depuis une semaine contre le pouvoir
géorgien et le nouveau premier ministre
nommé là semaine dernière
irakli garibal billy depuis octobre des
milliers de personnes exigent nouveau
scrutin après la victoire controversée
du parti au pouvoir lors des
législatives des élections marquées par
les fraudes et les pressions politiques
selon les opposants
mardi dernier la contestation s'est
encore durcie après l'arrestation du
chef du principal parti d'opposition
dans ce contexte de plus en plus tendue
l'union européenne a donc décidé
d'intervenir
une réunion entre tous les partis
politiques le premier ministre géorgien
et charles michel doit avoir lieu dans
la soirée